so four days after the allegations of
abuse where do they stand taking
Johnny's side his daughter his ex
vanessa paradis his bodyguards and his
comedian friend on Amber's side their
next-door neighbor her friend Amanda de
Cadenet
her lawyer and Twitter activist who
started the hashtag I'm with amber
speaking out for Johnny his daughter
lily-rose instagrammed this pig say my
dad is the sweetest most loving person I
know vanessa paradis johnny's partner of
14 years allegedly han wrote this letter
posted on TMZ saying quote these recent
allegations being made are outrageous
and all the years I have known Johnny
he has never been physically abusive
then there's the bodyguard named in
Amber's court papers who allegedly
witnessed the fight that caused all of
this when Amber yelled quote stop
hitting me one report claims that two
guards will testify that Johnny was
actually 20 feet away in the kitchen
while amber was in the living room so
that has some asking if it's all about
blackmail that's what Johnny's comedian
friend Doug Stanhope says he wrote a
column saying Johnny told him that quote
amber was going to leave him threatening
to lie about him publicly if he didn't
agree to her terms
Danka also alleges that Johnny got used
manipulated set up as for Amber her
lawyers call the blackmail claim
unequivocally false they also give us a
statement calling amber a victim and a
hero who quote suffered through years of
physical and psychological abuse at the
hands of Johnny
Amber's longtime friend Amanda de
Cadenet posted this photo two days after
the alleged brawl the knelt deleted post
as amber smiling but her hair is
covering her allegedly bruised right eye
while it's unclear when the shot was
taken today the talk-show host
de Cadenet continues to retweet post
with the hashtag I'm with Amber and
today sources tell us they heard from
amber that Johnny injured his hand
punching a wall during an argument they
had in Australia in March last year that
could explain this picture Johnny's hand
in a cast as he left the set of pirates